a viewer reached out to 8 news now with
some concerns about an apartment complex
after some digging the i-team learned
from clark county the complex does not
have a license to operate vanessa murphy
talked with tenants and try to get some
answers from the landlord
tenants here at the apex apartments say
they knew something was wrong when they
stopped receiving their mail as the
i-team found out according to clark
county the apartment homes have been
operating without a license i'm missing
a lot of packages that i've ordered and
i've not gotten not one of them tina
friends says she's lived here at the
apartments near maryland and twain for
six years it's gone downhill so much the
i-team obtained this notice of violation
to the apex apartment's owner for
operating an unlicensed department homes
business it states failure or refusal to
obtain a license immediately could lead
to a citation and notice to appear in
court this notice is dated july 21st as
of august 16th a county spokesman tells
us there's still no license and the last
one was terminated on may 13th the
i-team also reached out to the u.s
postal service a spokesman says
management claims to have no license to
accept mail for their residence which is
preventing the mail carrier from
delivering mail and packages to the
apartment complex
so where is this money going we don't
know where it's going that's the type of
information we should have that's the
type of information we need the i-team
dug into county records which reveal the
property was sold in january we tracked
down the ownership to a california
address and we were told the landlord
will not comment this is just it's
disgusting tenants also point to repairs
not getting done trash on the property
and an inability to get answers about
their homes until i move i want to make
sure that the roof that i do have is
secure a county spokesman tells the
i-team a business license investigation
is ongoing reporting in las vegas
vanessa murphy 8 news now vanessa thanks
a usps spokesman says customers at the
apex apartments can pick up their mail
at the paradise valley post office a
county spokesman tells us that the
tenants at the apex apartments who have
applied to chap the current situation
should have no effect on their
application